يجتمع خبراء من الشرق الأوسط
هنا في أبو ظبي بتنظيم من
مبادرة N7 وهم يتطلعون إلى صياغة
التعاون أو الاستمرار فيه بينما يشغل
دان شابيرو منصب مدير
مبادرة N7 وهو زميل متميز
في برنامج الشرق الأوسط التابع للمجلس الأطلسي
وهو أيضًا عضو في  بالطبع جديد أو
الاعتراف به كسفير سابق للولايات المتحدة
في إسرائيل من عام 2011 إلى عام 2017
وهو هنا معي الآن، ما رأيك
بما يجري في الوقت الحاضر
وتأثير القضايا الداخلية
على العلاقات ليس فقط مع هذا
الجزء من إسرائيل؟  العالم ولكن معنا
أيضًا، أعتقد أن الكثير من قادة
جيران إسرائيل وقادة
أصدقاء وشركاء وحلفاء
إسرائيل الآخرين في الولايات المتحدة وأوروبا
ينظرون إلى وضع سياسي مضطرب للغاية وحتى
فوضوي داخل
إسرائيل وكذلك البعض.  تصاعد التوترات
بين الإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
والحاجة إلى التوقف مؤقتًا على الأقل لمعرفة ما
إذا كان بإمكانهم فهم إلى أين
سيذهب ذلك أه ما هي القرارات التي
سيتخذها الإسرائيليون أه من الواضح أن تلك
القرارات يمكن أن يكون لها تداعيات على
العلاقات الأخرى أه أعتقد في
حالة  الولايات المتحدة هناك
التزام كبير بالعلاقة مع
إسرائيل ومن الواضح أنها مبنية على
القيم المشتركة للديمقراطيتين، لذا
نأمل ألا يتم تعريض ذلك بأي شكل من الأشكال للخطر
من خلال القرارات التي
يتم اتخاذها ولكن من الواضح تمامًا أننا  عندما
نسمع من مسؤولين أمريكيين أن هذا الأمر
في خطر بينما يواصلون
القول بأن أمننا يضمن لنا Ironclad، كما
تعلمون كان لويد أوستن
مؤخرًا ولكن الوزير يومض قبل ذلك وهو
يتحدث
أو يتحدث بالتأكيد عن موضوع
التهديد للديمقراطية ويتحدث بشكل جيد
حول  فكرة أه عند إجراء
تغييرات أساسية أه في
نظام الحكم في
النظام الديمقراطي من المهم أن يكون هناك حوار من
المهم أن تكون هناك شفافية ومن
المهم أن يكون هناك
إجماع واسع قدر الإمكان وربما لا يتم
التسرع لأنه يتطلب  حان الوقت
لبناء هذا الإجماع،
أعتقد أنها نقاط مهمة
جعل هؤلاء المسؤولون بنيامين نتنياهو
فخورًا للغاية
بالمحاكم الإبراهيمية، الصفقات التي تم إبرامها
لتطبيع العلاقات بين الإمارات
والبحرين والمغرب وإلى
حد ما السودان في عام 2020.  ما يريده وما
تريده الولايات المتحدة هو أن تقوم إسرائيل
بتطبيع العلاقات مع المملكة العربية السعودية،
وهو ما لا يبدو كخيار مطروح على
الطاولة في الوقت الحالي، لأسباب ليس أقلها
ما يجري في الضفة الغربية
أم
يمكن للسعوديين أن يعرضوا على بنيامين
نتنياهو حلاً.  خارج الطريق إذا أرادوا ذلك،
فلنفكر في ما يحدث
محليًا وبعد ذلك قد نفكر
في التطبيع الذي ترغب فيه الولايات المتحدة
وهذا الجزء من العالم
يرغب في ذلك أيضًا ولكن في الوقت الحالي
ما إذا كان سيتم تقديم عرض أم لا
إنه لا يتقبل الأمر، فما مدى
أهمية ما يقرر بنيامين نتنياهو
فعله بعد ذلك
بشأن ما يحدث لإسرائيل في هذه
المنطقة وفي أماكن أخرى، أعتقد أن
الدول التي قامت بالفعل بتطبيع
دياناتها مع إسرائيل، الإمارات العربية المتحدة،
البحرين، المغرب، اتخذت بالفعل
قرارًا استراتيجيًا للقيام به  أنني لا
أعتقد أن هؤلاء معرضون للخطر، لا أعتقد
أنهم معرضون للخطر، أعتقد أنه قد يكون هناك
بعض الحذر أه يتسلل إلى هذه الوتيرة
من الخطوات الإضافية التي يتم اتخاذها
وبالتأكيد قد لا يكون هذا هو الجو
الذي يمكنك فيه  أتوقع
دول إضافية ربما السعوديين أه تضيف
أسمائهم إلى تلك القائمة ولكن أعتقد أن
تلك العلاقات استراتيجية
أنا هنا مع مبادرة N7 إنها
شراكة مشتركة أه مع
مجلس أتلانتا في مؤسسة جيفري إم تالبينس
لدينا خبراء من  أه 10
إسرائيلي إسرائيلي و 10 دول عربية
يجتمعون معا أه
خبراءهم الحكوميين وغير الحكوميين لمحاولة وضع
مشاريع ومقترحات ستجلب فعلا
فوائد التطبيع
للمواطنين في الزراعة والأمن المائي
والغذائي كل الضغوطات التي
تتعلق بالأعمال  أليس هذا بمثابة
فصل لملف الأعمال عن
الملفات السياسية، ولكن أيضًا تلك
التحديات المشتركة، التحديات الناجمة عن المناخ المتمثلة في
ندرة المياه
والزراعة الصحراوية، وهذه هي الأشياء التي يمكنهم
التعاون بشأنها حتى في لحظات
التوتر السياسي ولذلك نحاول
تسهيل تلك الأمور  تؤدي المحادثات إلى تطوير
شبكة من الخبراء الذين يمكنهم القيام بذلك
معًا حتى عندما تكون هناك لحظات من
التوتر أو الحذر على
المستوى السياسي. هذه فكرة لك وأنا
متأكد من أنك تفكر في هذا أو
أنك تناقش هذا الأمر.
الدولة التي تشجع بشكل كبير
ليس فقط الاستثمار
ولكن المواهب في الوقت الحاضر، ماذا عن
الفرص المتاحة هنا في الإمارات العربية المتحدة
لرجال الأعمال الإسرائيليين وخاصة
رجال الأعمال في قطاع التكنولوجيا الذين
يشعرون
أن ما يحدث محليًا
له تأثير حقيقي على المستثمر
الاهتمام بإسرائيل والشركات الإسرائيلية،
ماذا عن فرصة
رجال الأعمال الإسرائيليين للمجيء والانتقال إلى
الإمارات العربية المتحدة هو خيار في هذه المرحلة،
حسنًا، ترى أن هذا كان يحدث
حتى قبل التيار، هل ترى
تسارعًا أعتقد أنه من السابق لأوانه القيام بذلك
أحكم أنه بالتأكيد كان هناك أه
بعض القلق الذي عبرت عنه أه مختلف
القطاعات في مجتمع الأعمال الإسرائيلي
بشأن الإصلاح القضائي
المطروح لكن حتى قبل
ذلك أه التقيت أمس مع
السفير الإسرائيلي لدى الإمارات وتحدث
عن مضاعفة التجارة الثنائية
بين البلدين في أه من
عام 2021 إلى عام 2022. أصبحت الإمارات الآن واحدة من
أكبر الشركاء التجاريين لإسرائيل
بعد عامين فقط من سجلات أبراهام
والكثير من ذلك مدفوع من قبل
الشركات الإسرائيلية التي قررت أنها يمكن أن تحقق
الربح مرة أخرى بشكل منفصل عن
الاضطراب السياسي من خلال وجود
موقع استيطاني على الأقل في دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة، نعم هذا
رائع، أليس كذلك لأنه سيكون من
المثير للاهتمام حقًا رؤية كيف
تبدو الأرقام هذا العام أم
ما سيحدث بعد ذلك،
ما سيحدث بعد ذلك، أخبرني جيدًا بما
سيحدث بعد ذلك، أه أولاً
يتعين على الحكومة الإسرائيلية أن تستمر في العمل
ويجب أن أقول إن
الشعب الإسرائيلي هو أحد الأشياء التي
تحدث عنها الوزير بلينكن أيضًا عندما كان في
إسرائيل، وهي حيوية الديمقراطية
التي تتم مناقشة هذه القضايا
في الكنيست ولكن أيضًا  في
الشارع وأه شعب إسرائيل وحكومة
إسرائيل يجب أن
يتخذوا معًا بعض القرارات نأمل أن
تصل إلى درجة معينة من الإجماع
الرئيس إسحاق هرتسوغ يحاول
تطوير عملية إجماع أه لكن
أعتقد حتى نعرف نوعاً ما نتيجة
أنه من الصعب أن نقول ما يحدث
الآن دان شابيرو هل ترى
الجناح الديني اليميني في هذه
الحكومة الائتلافية الذي يعجبك أم لا بنيامين
نتنياهو في الوقت الحاضر هل
تراهم يتراجعون
عن أي من مطالبهم وهذه
المطالب هي هذه  تغييرات مثيرة للجدل للغاية
في السلطة القضائية هنا تبدو أنها
نوع مختلف من الائتلاف عن أي
ائتلاف حكم إسرائيل سابقًا حتى الائتلافات اليمينية لم يكن لديها
هذه الغلبة تمامًا
من أه تلك المجتمعات وتلك وجهات النظر
العالمية نعم أو لا، هل سيذهبون
للتراجع جيدًا أنا أقوم بأي
تنبؤات بشأن سياسة دولة أخرى
أه إنه وضع متوتر للغاية
مازلت أقضي الكثير من الوقت في إسرائيل أه
ويمكنك أن تشعر بهذا التوتر أه يمكنك أن
تشعر بالناس أه الذين يدعمون ما
تفعله الحكومة أه  نوع من إعطائها
هذا الدعم ولكن يمكنك أيضًا
بالطبع رؤية هؤلاء أه مئات الآلاف
من المتظاهرين يخرجون أه
أكثر من مرة في الأسبوع الآن أه
ليقولوا حقًا أن هذه ليست إسرائيل التي نحن
مخلصون لها ونؤمن بها ونريد أه
للتوصل إلى بعض الإجماع، لا نريد
أن يكون هناك جانب واحد من هذا
الانقسام السياسي يفرض قراراته على
الآخرين، ونأمل مرة أخرى أن تكون
قيادة الرئيس هرتسوغ هي
نوع النتيجة التي يمكنهم تحقيقها، من
الجيد أن يكون لديك، من الجيد دائمًا أن
يكون لديك  لقد تحدثنا أنا وأنت كثيرًا
هنا، تهانينا،
نحن سعداء تمامًا بهذا
الاستوديو الجديد وآمل أن يكون المشاهدون
رائعين جدًا بحيث لا يتمكنون من رؤيتك تأتي ورؤيتنا مرة أخرى
عندما تكون في المدينة، شكرًا
للأجانب.